I'm Dal LaMagna. Ira Glass will be here in a minute. Just bear with me. I was heading to the Middle East, and there were friends of mine who had been there before and they gave me some tips.
我是 Dal LaMagna。Ira Glass 一会儿就到。请耐心等我一下。我正要前往中东，以前去过那里的朋友给了我一些建议。
Salam aleikum.
愿主平安（Salam aleikum）。
愿主平安。
That's it.
就是这样。
Alaikum salam.
愿主也平安（Alaikum salam）。
愿主也平安。
Aleikum salam. So do I say salam aleikum first?
愿主也平安。那我应该先说“愿主平安”吗？
Depends.
看情况。
It's a mutual exchange. You'll probably both say it at the same time.
这是一种相互交流。你们俩很可能会同时说出来。
Salam aleikum.
愿主平安。
Aleikum salam.
愿主也平安。
And say that everywhere. That's going to be very good for you.
到处都这么说。这对你会很有好处。
The day before I went, I stopped by Tony, who is a friend of mine and my tailor, to get some clothes.
出发前一天，我顺路去找了我的裁缝朋友 Tony，拿些衣服。
You're sure you're not going to wear a tuxedo there? I thought for sure you'd have to wear the tuxedo.
你确定不去那里穿燕尾服吗？我敢肯定你得穿燕尾服。
I'm not going to any parties. I'm meeting with the resistance.
我又不参加派对。我要去会见抵抗组织。
Oh.
哦。
I'm having meetings with sheikhs. You know?
我要去会见谢赫（部落首领）。你懂的？
The sheikhs know good clothes.
谢赫们懂好衣服。
No, they do. They're all dressed in their--
不，他们确实懂。他们都穿着他们的——
They know nice clothes.
他们懂好衣服。
I had dinner at my sister's house the night before I left with her and her husband. I was going to Iraq hoping to do some good there. And they weren't very keen about it at all.
出发前一晚，我在姐姐家和她及她丈夫共进晚餐。我当时要去伊拉克，希望能在那儿做点好事。但他们一点也不支持。
Well at least you're trying to do something. I think you're crazy, but at least you're trying to do something.
好吧，至少你在尝试做些什么。我觉得你疯了，但至少你在尝试做些什么。
Don Quixote.
唐吉诃德。
See the attitude I get from people about what I'm doing? OK, here's Ira Glass.
看看人们对我的所作所为是什么态度？好了，Ira Glass 来了。
Thanks Dal LaMagna. As you can hear, Dal is somebody who is capable of a lot of things, opening a radio show for instance. And the reason that Dal was going to Iraq was to end the violence there. Literally, to broker a ceasefire between the Sunni resistance and the coalition forces. Basically, he wanted to get Iraqis to stop shooting at Americans.
谢谢 Dal LaMagna。正如你所听到的，Dal 是一个能力很强的人，比如能开办一个广播节目。Dal 去伊拉克的原因是为了结束那里的暴力冲突。从字面上讲，就是为了促成逊尼派抵抗组织和联军之间的停火。基本上，他想让伊拉克人停止向美国人开火。
He doesn't speak Arabic. He's got no policy making experience. He's not a diplomat, or a CIA agent, or an ex-Marine. He's not Bono. He's just a guy, which brings us to today's program. Dal, give them the ID.
他不会说阿拉伯语。他没有政策制定经验。他不是外交官，不是中情局特工，也不是退役海军陆战队员。他不是 Bono。他只是个普通人，这就要引出今天的节目了。Dal，做个自我介绍。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Want me to do it again?
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司分发。要我重来一遍吗？
No, that was perfect. Today on our show, Man vs. History, we have two stories in two different acts of two different men, regular guys, taking history into their own hands. Stay with us.
不，那很完美。今天在我们的节目“人与历史”中，我们将讲述两个不同篇章里的两个不同男人的故事，他们都是普通人，将历史掌握在自己手中。请继续收听。
Act One. Well we heard about Dal LaMagna actually by reading about him in the newspaper. There was this article in the New York Times about a Sunni politician from Iraq who was in Washington, DC lobbying on Capitol Hill. And this article mentioned a tweezer magnate, the maker of the Tweezerman tweezer, which at that time I had never heard of, but since then, all the women in my life have informed me is the greatest thing ever.
第一幕。我们是通过报纸读到 Dal LaMagna 的。当时《纽约时报》有一篇关于一位伊拉克逊尼派政治家在华盛顿特区国会山游说的文章。文章提到了一个镊子大亨，Tweezerman 镊子的制造商，当时我从未听说过，但从那以后，我生命中所有的女性都告诉我，那是史上最好的东西。
And this Tweezerman guy, Dal LaMagna, was doing all kinds of things with his millions to advance peace in the Middle East, including setting up meetings between this Sunni politician and members of Congress. But at the time, he was planning what was going to be his biggest project of all, the thing you heard him talk about at the beginning of the show. This mission to get the Sunni resistance to sit down with coalition forces and try to get to terms for a ceasefire.
而这个 Tweezerman 先生，Dal LaMagna，正在利用他的数百万美元做各种事情来推动中东和平，包括安排这位逊尼派政治家与国会议员会面。但当时，他正在计划他最大的项目，也就是你在节目开头听到的那个。他的使命是让逊尼派抵抗组织与联军坐下来，试图达成停火条款。
We heard about that and we wondered, how this is going to go? And so we called him up. And we asked him if he would be willing to take a little recorder with him. He came back with over 25 hours of sound. And This American Life producer Sarah Koenig sifted through all that sound and then had Dal come into the studio to talk about it. Here's Sarah.
我们听说了这件事，心想，这会进展得如何？于是我们给他打了电话。我们问他是否愿意带个小录音机去。他带回了超过 25 小时的音频。《美国生活》制作人 Sarah Koenig 梳理了所有这些音频，然后让 Dal 来到演播室谈论这件事。下面是 Sarah 的报道。
When Dal LaMagna gets an idea, he charges at it with everything he's got. He has bankrolled movies. He ran for Congress in 1996 and spent $1 million of his own money on his campaign, literally all of his money at the time, and lost. And then four years later, he ran again. He's the kind of guy who would run for president even though he has no hope of actually becoming president. In fact, right now he is running for president.
当 Dal LaMagna 有了个想法，他会全力以赴地去执行。他曾资助过电影。他在 1996 年竞选国会议员，在竞选中花了 100 万美元的个人积蓄，实际上当时他所有的钱都花了，结果落选了。四年后，他又参选了。他就是那种即使毫无希望也会去竞选总统的人。事实上，他现在正在竞选总统。
And so when he got frustrated lobbying Washington about the war, he figured, why try to convince congressmen to convince the president to set a new course with the Iraqis? Cut out the middleman. And so, back in June, he boarded a Royal Jordanian Airlines flight, fell sleep and woke up in Amman, Jordan where his ceasefire project would begin.
所以当他在华盛顿游说战争问题感到沮丧时，他想，为什么要费力去说服国会议员去说服总统与伊拉克人开辟新路线呢？直接跳过中间人。于是，回到六月，他登上了皇家约旦航空公司的航班，睡着了，醒来时已经在约旦安曼，他的停火项目将从那里开始。
Address here?
这边的地址？
My address here? I'm staying with Mohammed al-Dynee. al-Dynee. He's a member of the Iraq Parliament. We're staying here.
我在这儿的地址吗？我住在 Mohammed al-Dynee 那儿。al-Dynee。他是伊拉克议会的成员。我们住这儿。
Dal met Mohammed al-Dynee, the Sunni politician we read about in that New York Times article when Mohammed came to Washington, DC. He's one of the youngest members of Iraq's parliament, and he stayed at Dal's house for three weeks while Dal took him around Congress. And now Mohammed had invited Dal to come stay at his place in Amman. Amman is where lots of Iraqi political players are living now that it's so dangerous in Iraq. So Amman is where Dal and Mohammed will begin to map out a peace agreement for one of the largest regional conflicts in the world. Their strategy? Meetings, lots of meetings.
Dal 在那篇《纽约时报》文章中读到的那位逊尼派政治家 Mohammed al-Dynee 到华盛顿特区时，Dal 见了他。他是伊拉克议会最年轻的成员之一，他在 Dal 家住了三周，Dal 带着他跑遍了国会。现在 Mohammed 邀请 Dal 去他在安曼的住处。由于伊拉克局势险恶，许多伊拉克政治人物现在都住在安曼。所以安曼就是 Dal 和 Mohammed 开始为世界上最大地区冲突之一起草和平协议的地方。他们的策略？开会，大量的会议。
Tomorrow morning, we're meeting Sheikh Harith al-Dari.
明天早上，我们要见 Harith al-Dari 谢赫。
Oh, really.
哦，真的吗。
Dal's first meeting is with Sheikh Harith al-Dari, a Sunni cleric so important, the story goes, that President Bush has tried to meet with him and the sheikh has declined. And if you're asking why he turned down the president of the United States but said yes to Tweezerman, here's why. Dal had unwittingly become a big deal in Mohammed's political circle because of Mohammed's trip to DC.
Dal 的第一次会面是与 Harith al-Dari 谢赫，一位非常重要的逊尼派教士，据说布什总统曾试图见他，但被他拒绝了。如果你问为什么他拒绝了美国总统却答应了 Tweezerman，原因如下。因为 Mohammed 的 DC 之行，Dal 在不知不觉中成了 Mohammed 政治圈里的重要人物。
Dal had thought the trip was kind of a bust. Even the New York Times story wasn't exactly positive. It suggested that Mohammed might be a liar, or worse a criminal, which Dal thought was ridiculous, but still. And they didn't meet nearly as many congressmen as they wanted.
Dal 本以为那次旅行是个失败。连《纽约时报》的文章也不完全是正面的。它暗示 Mohammed 可能是一个骗子，甚至更糟是一个罪犯，Dal 认为这很荒谬，但事实确实如此。而且他们见到的国会议员远没有他们预想的那么多。
I was very disappointed, but from Mohammed's point of view, and from everybody who he represented this point of view back there, he was the first member of parliament from the national side to get any voice. From their point of view, the story in the New York Times was terrific. The fact that it was a full page story with a picture and the fact that I was the one who facilitated it, raised my status dramatically amongst all these nationalist forces.
我非常失望，但从 Mohammed 的角度来看，以及他所代表的所有人的观点来看，他是来自民族方第一个发出声音的议员。在他们看来，《纽约时报》的报道很棒。它是全版报道且配有照片，而我正是促成此事的人，这使我在所有这些民族主义力量中的地位显著提高。
This first meeting with Sheikh Harith al-Dari is arguably the most important meeting he'll have his whole trip. Al-Dari is considered hugely influential in Sunni resistance groups, some of the same groups the American government calls insurgents. Their plan is that once Dal has gotten in with Sheikh al-Dari, they can then go see the US commanders in Baghdad. Dal can announce that he's met with the sheikh, the same one they've been trying to talk to but can't. And after that, Dal will become the liaison between the Sunni resistance and the US forces. And they can start to talk ceasefire.
与 Harith al-Dari 谢赫的第一次会面可以说是他整趟行程中最重要的一次。Al-Dari 被认为在逊尼派抵抗组织中有巨大的影响力，也就是美国政府所说的叛乱组织。他们的计划是，一旦 Dal 与 al-Dari 谢赫建立了联系，他们就可以去见巴格达的美军指挥官。Dal 可以宣布他见过谢赫了，就是他们一直想谈却谈不到的那位。此后，Dal 将成为逊尼派抵抗组织和美军之间的联络人。他们就可以开始商谈停火了。
So I just left my meeting with Sheikh Harith al-Dari. I wasn't allowed to record it. And so I frantically wrote notes. I've got 35 pages. And the sheikh has a very, very gentle face. He's a very calm man. And we go? OK.
所以我刚结束与 Harith al-Dari 谢赫的会面。我不被允许录音。所以我拼命记笔记。我有 35 页。谢赫有一张非常非常温和的脸。他是一个非常冷静的人。我们走吧？好的。
It's two o'clock in the morning. I'm still up. Everybody else is in bed. Yesterday I went to see the sheikh. I guess I would have to admit I was a little nervous. Well this meeting went on for three hours. I was starting to get hot. I was in my suit. And I was looking for my opportunity to ask him the question that I wanted to ask him. Thinking that he actually had the power to call a ceasefire against American soldiers, I said to him, "Look, here's the situation. You need to do something unexpected. If you can do something unexpected, you could break through this stalemate. And an unexpected thing to do would be for the resistance to have a ceasefire, to stop shooting at the American soldiers and to concentrate on Al-Qaeda."
现在是凌晨两点。我还没睡。其他人都睡了。昨天我去见了谢赫。我想我得承认我有点紧张。这次会面持续了三个小时。我开始觉得热了。我穿着西装。我在寻找机会问他我想问的问题。我以为他真的有权力呼吁针对美军停火，我对他说：“看，情况是这样的。你需要做一些出人意料的事情。如果你能做些出人意料的事，你就能打破僵局。而一件出人意料的事就是抵抗组织实现停火，停止向美军射击，并将重点转向基地组织。”
He looked at me and said, "You know, I can't tell the Iraqis what to do. The Iraqis do what they do and what they want to do. They are against the occupation. And for me, the only way I can influence them is if the Americans announced that they were going to withdraw." Of course as of now, no Iraqi believes America will ever withdraw.
他看着我说：“你知道，我不能告诉伊拉克人该做什么。伊拉克人做他们想做的事。他们反对占领。对我来说，只有当美国宣布撤军时，我才能影响他们。”当然，截至目前，没有伊拉克人相信美国会撤军。
And when I went outside, my first though was how I was a little disappointed.
当我走出来时，我第一个想法是我有多么失望。
But this meeting did two things for Dal. First, the simple fact that he had met with the sheikh, like an audience with royalty, made him someone who everyone wanted to meet with. And second, now at least he knew the starting point for negotiations. The sheikh wouldn't lean on the Sunnis unless the Americans announced a withdrawal. Since America wasn't about to announce a withdrawal, somewhere in there, he'd have to find some wiggle room.
但这次会面为 Dal 做了两件事。首先，他见过谢赫这一简单事实，就像觐见皇室成员一样，使他成为了每个人都想见的人。其次，现在他至少知道了谈判的起点。除非美国宣布撤军，否则谢赫不会向逊尼派施压。由于美国不可能宣布撤军，他必须在其中找到一些回旋余地。
But this is just day one, a Tuesday. By the following Tuesday, Dal had sat through 15 meetings. There was a school teacher who survived an assassination attempt. Iraq's former minister of oil, a guy who was injured in a suicide bombing. Iraq's ambassador to Jordan, people from Diyala, Anbar, Baghdad Amarah Kirkuk. There was another very important sheikh, this time a shia, who came all the way from Syria just to see Dal.
但那只是第一天，周二。到了下个周二，Dal 已经参加了 15 场会议。有一位在暗杀企图中幸存的学校老师。伊拉克前石油部长，一个在自杀式炸弹袭击中受伤的人。伊拉克驻约旦大使，来自迪亚拉、安巴尔、巴格达、阿马拉、基尔库克的人。还有另一位非常重要的谢赫，这次是一位什叶派，特意从叙利亚赶来见 Dal。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说着外语]
The fact that if the American troops stay in Iraq, it will definitely lead to a civil war.
如果美军留在伊拉克，那肯定会导致内战的事实。
A chief of one of the largest Kurdish tribes.
最大的库尔德部落之一的酋长。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说着外语]。
He is saying, with respect, Bush himself has said that he made a mistake.
他说，恕我直言，布什自己也说过他犯了一个错误。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
[说着外语]。
Condoleezza Rice says we made thousands of mistakes.
康多莉扎·赖斯说我们犯了几千个错误。
A group of seven argumentative parliamentarians.
一群好辩的议会议员。
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
[交错的杂音]。
Were you ever thinking, I'm not the guy they think I am? I mean did you ever just worry, they're thinking I'm more influential than I am?
你有没有想过，“我不是他们以为的那个人”？我的意思是，你有没有担心过，他们以为你比实际更有影响力？
No, never occurred to me. I don't think that way. I'm an entrepreneur. My entire life, that's what I am, an entrepreneur. And what is an entrepreneur? An entrepreneur is somebody who makes things happen. And I'm making things happen. And I'm not thinking about, oh well, I'm not an important enough person to do this. I'm just making the things happen. And certainly if it was Bill Clinton doing it or Jimmy Carter doing it or anybody else, yeah, it would be big news. And there would be conversations about it. But they're not doing it. So I'm doing it.
不，从未想过。我不那样思考。我是个企业家。我的一生，这就是我的本质，一个企业家。什么是企业家？企业家就是能让事情发生的人。我正在让事情发生。我没有在想，哦，我不够重要，做不了这个。我只是在让事情发生。当然，如果是比尔·克林顿或吉米·卡特或其他任何人做这件事，是的，那会是重大新闻。也会有相关的讨论。但他们没做。所以我做了。
When you think about how many experts there are out there in this stuff and how many people have been working their whole careers on solving the problems in the Middle East, the fact that you would even fantasize about that sounds a little grandiose and crazy.
当你考虑到这个领域有多少专家，有多少人为了解决中东问题奋斗了整个职业生涯，而你居然幻想能做到，这听起来有点宏大且疯狂。
I don't think it's crazy. I'm not a crazy person. I'm a person who, when I founded Tweezerman 25 years ago and I was walking around with this tweezer. And people were saying to me-- I was going to build a company around it-- and they were saying, you should sell it to Revlon. Or you should do this, you should do that. How are you ever going to it out? And there are always naysayers, always people who can't imagine how anybody can accomplish any of the great things that we aspire to. And I did it. And the thought that one could do great things is a reasonable thought. It's not a crazy thought.
我不觉得疯狂。我不是个疯子。我是一个人在 25 年前创立 Tweezerman 时，带着这把镊子走来走去。人们对我说——我打算围绕它建立一家公司——他们对我说，你应该把它卖给露华浓（Revlon）。或者你应该这样做，那样做。你怎么可能成功？总会有怀疑者，总会有人无法想象别人如何能实现我们所渴望的任何伟大目标。但我做到了。能做成大事的想法是一个合理的想法。这不是个疯狂的想法。
The Iraqis he's talking to, mostly Sunnis, call themselves nationalists, which means they want a secular government that's fair to everyone, Sunni, Shia and Kurd. And so all of them have plenty of complaints about the current Shia led government of Nouri al-Maliki, which has reported ties to Shia militias and death squads. They also hate Iran. But Dal is more interested in solutions than complaints. And he tries to push the conversations toward practical ideas.
他交谈的那些伊拉克人，大多是逊尼派，自称民族主义者，意思是他们想要一个对所有人都公平的世俗政府，无论是逊尼派、什叶派还是库尔德人。所以他们对当前努里·马利基领导的什叶派政府有很多抱怨，该政府据传与什叶派民兵和死亡小队有联系。他们也痛恨伊朗。但 Dal 对解决问题比抱怨更感兴趣。他试图将对话引向实用的想法。
And the solution then is?
那么解决方案是？
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说着外语]
The solution is to burn Iran from east to west.
解决方案是从东到西烧毁伊朗。
Burn Iran from east to west. That's a member of parliament talking by the way. And all this time, Dal is trying to make sense of what he's hearing. Remember, his specialty is selling personal grooming products so even the basics are new to him.
从东到西烧毁伊朗。顺便说一下，那是一位议员说的话。而此时此刻，Dal 正试图理解他所听到的东西。记住，他的专长是销售个人护理产品，所以即使是基础知识对他来说也是新的。
I thought Al-Qaeda came from Saudi Arabia.
我以为基地组织来自沙特阿拉伯。
No, they didn't come.
不，他们不是来自那儿。
Any come from Saudi Arabia?
有来自沙特阿拉伯的吗？
Jihad is a fight, fighting for your rights.
圣战是一种斗争，为了你的权利而奋斗。
And what is mujahideen?
那什么是“圣战者”（mujahideen）？
Mujahideen means fighters.
圣战者意味着战士。
And I'm confused. Talabani is the president of Iraq. He has a brother?
我糊涂了。塔拉巴尼是伊拉克总统。他有个兄弟？
In the 25 hours of Dal's recordings, of course there are moments like this. But there's another side too. We all read the same newspaper stories. We all sit at home and feel horrible about the war. Dal actually did something about it. He found his way to Iraqi politicians. He got on a plane. He's trying.
在 Dal 录下的 25 小时里，当然有这样的时刻。但也有另一面。我们都读过同样的报纸报道。我们都坐在家里对战争感到恐惧。Dal 真的为此采取了行动。他找到了通往伊拉克政客的门路。他上了飞机。他在努力。
I'm sitting at the pool at the Marriott hotel at the Dead Sea in Amman, Jordan. So I'm here sitting thinking about this whole idea of what am I doing. Why am I here? What can one American with absolutely no political access-- well, I've learned something from my mother. And that is if your enemy knows you, and you know him, really well, and the better you know each  other, the harder it is to maintain a fight.
我坐在约旦安曼死海万豪酒店的泳池边。我坐在这里思考关于我正在做的这件事的整个想法。我为什么在这里？一个完全没有政治背景的美国人能做什么——好吧，我从我母亲那里学到了一些东西。那就是如果你的敌人了解你，你也了解他，非常了解，你们越了解对方，就越难维持一场战斗。
My mother used to tie my sister and myself together when we would have our flights until we made up. And it always worked. After being tied together for however long it was, next thing you know we were laughing about it, and we weren't fighting anymore.
我母亲以前在我们打架时会把我姐姐和我绑在一起，直到我们和好。这总是奏效。被绑在一起无论多久后，接下来的事情你就会发现我们正对此大笑，不再争斗了。
Maybe we get the resistance together with the generals for a weekend at one of these resorts. And have them hang out, and eat dinner together, and eat lunch together and go swimming together.
也许我们可以让抵抗组织和将军们在这些度假胜地之一度过周末。让他们聚在一起，一起吃晚饭，一起吃午饭，一起游泳。
It's three o'clock Amman time. One of my assistants back in America sent me a link to a Seattle Times posting about the sheikh that I visited the first day I was here. And whoa, just a string of hate comments, people calling me a moron and a traitor. And who the hell do I think I am? Not one positive comment. I mean here I am trying to talk a sheikh into a ceasefire against our soldiers, and they're calling me a traitor.
安曼时间三点。我在美国的助手之一发给我一个《西雅图时报》的链接，是关于我到这儿第一天访问的那位谢赫的。哇，简直是一连串的仇恨评论，人们叫我白痴和叛徒。我以为我是谁啊？没有一条正面评论。我是说我在这里试图说服一位谢赫实现针对我们士兵的停火，他们却叫我叛徒。
After a week in Jordan, Mohammed gets a call that Dal's visa to Iraq is ready. As always on this trip, he's getting the kind of treatment a high-level diplomat would get. The Iraqi ambassador to Jordan has personally expedited his paperwork. So now they're ready to go to Baghdad. And they get another important message.
在约旦待了一周后，Mohammed 接到通知，说 Dal 去伊拉克的签证准备好了。和这次旅行中的所有事情一样，他得到的待遇是高级外交官才能得到的。伊拉克驻约旦大使亲自加急办理了他的手续。现在他们准备去巴格达了。他们又收到了一个重要信息。
The big news is that we actually got a meeting with General Petraeus, which is something we've been trying to do for the last four months, at 11:20 tomorrow in Baghdad at the embassy. We're leaving tomorrow morning on a seven o'clock flight. And so I need to bring a suit, right?
重大新闻是，我们真的得到了与彼得雷乌斯将军会面的机会，这是我们过去四个月一直试图做的事情，明天 11 点 20 分在巴格达的使馆。我们明天早上搭乘七点的航班离开。所以我需要带一套西装，对吧？
OK, we're here an hour and a half before the plane leaves. So I think it was my tweezers that stopped us at the gate.
好了，我们在飞机起飞前一个半小时到了这儿。所以我认为是因为我的镊子在登机口拦住了我们。
Yeah well, I'm looking down today at Baghdad. It looks like any other place. Well, there aren't too many trees down there. Looks relatively calm.
是啊，我今天俯瞰巴格达。它看起来和其他地方没什么两样。嗯，下面的树不是很多。看起来相对平静。
Dal puts on body armor and they head to the Green Zone, where they're scheduled to meet with General David Petraeus, who's in charge of US forces in Iraq. Petraeus's assistant, Mary Kohler, has set it up. And Dal, Mohammed and [? Hasam, ?] their translator, wait for her outside the American embassy so she can escort them in as VIPs.
Dal 穿上防弹衣，他们前往绿区，计划在那里会见负责驻伊美军的戴维·彼得雷乌斯将军。彼得雷乌斯的助理 Mary Kohler 安排了这次会面。Dal、Mohammed 和他们的翻译 Hasam 在美国大使馆外等她，以便她能以贵宾身份护送他们进去。
Mary?
Mary？
I'm sorry. The General has just been called away. That's why I'm late. So I'm going to have you meet with Major General Newton.
对不起。将军刚被叫走了。这就是为什么我迟到了。所以我要让你们去见牛顿少将。
Oh God. I can't believe it.
天哪。我不敢相信。
He's really sorry.
他真的很抱歉。
Two hours earlier, the Shiite shrine in Samarra had been blown up for the second time, the most serious incident in months. And American commanders were scrambling. The government would declare a curfew and Baghdad would be shut down for days. But of course Dal knows none of this. Since Petraeus can't make it, Mary has arranged for them to sit down with the top British commanders, General Graeme Lamb and Major General Paul Newton. Lamb is in charge of reconciliation in Iraq.
两个小时前，萨迈拉的什叶派圣殿第二次被炸毁，这是数月来最严重的事件。美国指挥官们乱作一团。政府宣布宵禁，巴格达将被封锁数日。但 Dal 当然对此一无所知。由于彼得雷乌斯无法出席，Mary 安排他们与英国最高指挥官格雷姆·兰姆将军和保罗·牛顿少将坐下来谈。兰姆负责伊拉克的和解工作。
You can tell this is the British office.
你可以看出这是英国办公室。
Exactly. Basically--
正是。基本上——
And so you fit in where?
那你属于哪一方？
I'm Dal LaMagna.
我是 Dal LaMagna。
Got it.
明白了。
I'm a citizen diplomat. I'm not--
我是公民外交官。我不是——
This is what all the meetings had been leading up to. Dal would help Mohammed present the Sunni resistance position to the coalition forces. Finally, he was bringing the two sides together. But right away, the meeting goes off course. First of all, nobody seems much impressed that Dal has met with Sheikh Harith al-Dari, Dal's supposed pipeline to the bigwigs in the Sunni resistance slash insurgency. Sure, al-Dari is a big deal, but he's sitting in Jordan.
这就是所有会议要引出的结果。Dal 将帮助 Mohammed 向联军陈述逊尼派抵抗组织的立场。终于，他把双方拉到了一起。但会议一开始就偏离了轨道。首先，似乎没有人对 Dal 会见过 Harith al-Dari 谢赫印象深刻，而那可是 Dal 所谓的通往逊尼派抵抗组织大佬的管道。当然，al-Dari 是个大人物，但他待在约旦。
Then Mohammed starts to argue with Lamb. "The Maliki government is corrupt," he says. "Then change it," Lamb says.
接着 Mohammed 开始与兰姆争论。“马利基政府是腐败的，”他说。“那就换掉它，”兰姆说。
But the constitution is very clear. If you wish to challenge the government through the constitutional process, that is open to this parliament.
但宪法非常明确。如果你希望通过宪法程序挑战政府，那是对议会开放的。
But Mohammed says even showing up to debate the constitution could get them killed by Maliki's people. This goes around and around. Mohammed raises all the complaints that Sunnis have been talking about all week in their meetings with Dal, the open border with Iran, how dangerous it is for Sunni members of parliament, the crooked Shia police. And the generals keep repeating, take it up with the Maliki government. And then Dal steps in.
但 Mohammed 说，即使出席宪法辩论也可能让他们被马利基的人杀掉。这就成了循环。Mohammed 提出了逊尼派整周在与 Dal 会面时谈论的所有抱怨，通往伊朗的边境开放，逊尼派议员有多危险，腐败的什叶派警察。而将军们一直重复，去向马利基政府反映。这时 Dal 插话了。
It's not useful here in this meeting to argue with the general about the failures and the problems with the Maliki government. It's just not useful because there's nothing they can do.
在这次会议上与将军争论马利基政府的失败和问题是没有用的。这没用，因为他们无能为力。
The top commanders in Iraq say they make it a practice to listen to nobodies who might turn out to be somebody. They're smart enough to know that they can't predict where progress might lurk. But they're not in the practice of wasting time. Finally General Newton asks them in his polite, British roundabout way, what exactly are you doing here?
伊拉克的高级指挥官们说，他们惯于倾听可能成为重要人物的无名小卒。他们足够聪明，知道自己无法预知进步可能潜伏在哪里。但他们没习惯浪费时间。终于，牛顿将军用那种礼貌、委婉的英国方式问他们，你们到底是来干什么的？
Do you mind if I ask a question? What General Lamb is painting here is that we are not in a position to do grand deals behind the back of the sovereign, elected government. However, naturally we have channels of communication open to people who can deliver a reduction in bombs. I am unclear exactly what is being proposed. That we should be put in touch with specific groups?
你不介意我问个问题吧？兰姆将军在这里描述的是，我们无权在主权选举产生的政府背后做大交易。然而，我们自然有与那些能带来炸弹袭击减少的人进行交流的渠道。我不太清楚到底提出了什么建议。是说我们应该与特定的组织接触吗？
What is being offered in the way of a practical opportunity for dialogue?
关于实际对话的机会提供了什么？
Here's when it becomes clear that the generals see them as essentially empty-handed. They'd love a ceasefire, but is anyone actually offering one?
这时很清楚，将军们认为他们基本上是空手而来。他们乐于见到停火，但有人真的在提供吗？
If there is a firm proposal involving being able to take that dialogue forward with armed groups, then I haven't heard what the specific proposal is.
如果有一个确定的提案，涉及能够与武装组织推进对话，那么我还没听到具体的提案是什么。
Right, that's good.
对，很好。
Mohammed speaks up.
Mohammed 发言了。
We have eight groups, eight major groups. Those people are ready to start talking, but it will be a confidential talk only with the coalition forces.
我们有八个组织，八个主要组织。这些人准备开始谈话，但仅限于与联军进行保密谈话。
That's constructive. So he has eight groups. We'll start a dialogue. And they'll decide how to handle it. But let's end on that note.
那有建设性。所以他有八个组织。我们将开始对话。他们会决定如何处理。但我们就此结束吧。
The generals don't say anything. The meeting ends. Everyone seems a little testy. But Dal is feeling hopeful, until as they're leaving, Lamb says something to Dal.
将军们什么也没说。会议结束了。每个人似乎都有点急躁。但 Dal 感到充满希望，直到他们离开时，兰姆对 Dal 说了些话。
For four years I've been having these conversations.
四年来我一直进行着这些对话。
Oh my God.
哦，我的天。
Lamb's parting shot to me was when I tried to get his contact information and he wouldn't give it to me was, look I've been doing this for four years. I can't tell you how many meetings I've had with people saying they represent the resistance or this is going to happen and that is going to happen. So he stuck a pin in the balloon that had filled up during that meeting at the very end. Yeah, so I went from one high to the low.
当我试图获取他的联系方式而他拒绝给我时，兰姆给我的临别赠言是，看，我已经做了四年了。我无法告诉你我与多少人开了会，说他们代表抵抗组织，或者这要发生那要发生。所以他在会议最后，把我那个充满希望的气球戳破了。是的，所以我从一个高潮跌落到了低谷。
Because he said that to you?
因为他对你说了那些话？
That that was like, oh my God, could this have just been theater? All right. This guy from America who's here. And he got here. He's here with this member of parliament. We have to meet with them. Let's just humor them.
那简直就像是，天哪，这难道只是表演吗？好吧。这个来自美国的家伙在这里。他到了这里。他和这位议员在一起。我们必须见他们。只是敷衍一下他们吧。
Well it was rather difficult for me to even get out of bed this morning after my meetings with these two generals yesterday. But there a moment there yesterday when I was in a meeting with General Lamb where I swore to myself that I was in one meeting and Mohammed was in another. And I just got the reality that the people I'm talking to, they're so out of the game, so deluded themselves into what is that can happen. And I don't mean to be disparaging. It's almost like I feel as if I should just pack up my bags and go home and forget the whole thing. And you're just feeling-- you run around and now you find out your assumptions about what can be done are wrong.
嗯，在昨天与这两位将军开会后，我今天早上甚至很难起床。但在昨天的会议中，有那么一刻，当我和兰姆将军在一起时，我发誓我当时在一场会议中，而 Mohammed 在另一场。我意识到与我交谈的这些人，他们离游戏太远了，对自己能发生的事情产生了幻觉。我不是要贬低谁。我感觉好像我应该收拾行李回家，把整件事忘掉。你只是感觉——你到处奔波，现在发现你对可以做什么的假设是错误的。
But he doesn't pack up and leave. He wakes up on Saturday and tells the tape recorder, "You don't wait for things to happen. The entrepreneurial way is to make things happen." After just two days, he's back on mission. He decides the generals weren't humoring him. They were giving him an opportunity. He and Mohammed just need to present them a concrete proposal, which they draw up, a three page document that's vague about a lot of things but does mention a timetable for US withdrawal and a ceasefire. Dal sends it to the generals. Weeks pass. He never hears anything back. Dal is pretty disappointed.
但他没有收拾行李离开。他周六醒来对录音机说：“你不要等事情发生。企业家的做法是让事情发生。”仅仅两天后，他又回到了任务中。他决定将军们并没有敷衍他。他们是在给他一个机会。他和 Mohammed 只需要向他们提出一个具体提案，他们起草了一份三页的文件，对许多事情含糊其辞，但确实提到了美军撤军的时间表和停火。Dal 把文件发给了将军们。几周过去了。他从未得到任何回音。Dal 非常失望。
We've had our meetings. Thank you very much. And it's over. I mean that's--
我们已经开了会。非常感谢。一切都结束了。我是说那是——
So you're not hopeful about--
所以你不抱希望了？
No.
不。
Does that mean you've given up?
这意味着你放弃了吗？
I've given up on the strategy of helping to broker a deal between the national forces and the coalition forces. I've given up on that. So now I'm on to the other strategy. One thing that I have to say about myself, and I think it's a good trait, is that I don't get trapped by my imagined solutions for things. When I can see it's not working, I move on and I try something else. And eventually I'll find something that does work.
我放弃了帮助促成民族力量与联军之间达成协议的策略。我放弃了那个。所以现在我转向了另一种策略。关于我自己我必须说的一点，我认为这是一个好品质，那就是我不会被我自己构思的解决方案所困住。当我看到它行不通时，我就转向并尝试其他东西。最终我会找到行得通的东西。
Here's his latest solution. He's using videotape of the meetings he held in Amman to make commercials. In them, Iraqis say point blank what they want us to do, which is leave Iraq. He's using them as the ads for his presidential campaign. And they're definitely unlike any other candidate advertising you've ever seen. He has gone from citizen diplomat to citizen ad man. He'll fight this war stateside for now.
这是他最新的解决方案。他正在利用他在安曼举行的会议的录像制作广告。在广告中，伊拉克人直言不讳地表达了他们想让我们做什么，那就是离开伊拉克。他正在把它们用作竞选总统的广告。它们绝对不同于你见过的任何其他候选人广告。他已经从公民外交官变成了公民广告人。他现在要在国内为这场战争而战。
Sarah Koenig. Coming up, we switch from America's current war to the good old days of the Cold War. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
Sarah Koenig。接下来，我们将从美国当前的战争切换到冷战的美好旧时光。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司继续我们的节目。
[MUSIC - "OVERTURE  FROM THE MAN OF LAMANCHA" BY ORIGINAL BROADWAY CAST RECORDING]
[音乐 - 原百老汇卡司录音《梦幻骑士序曲》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. This week on our show, Man vs. History, the stories of individuals taking action themselves during big historic moments. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Wenceslas Square. We have this short story about the final days of the Cold War from Arthur Phillips.
这是《美国生活》。我是 Ira Glass。本周在我们的节目“人与历史”中，讲述的是个人在重大历史时刻采取行动的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，瓦茨拉夫广场。我们有一个关于冷战最后日子的短篇故事，来自 Arthur Phillips。
In October of 1988, Tyler Vanalden received his second CIA posting, his first in the Communist bloc. He was dispatched to Prague, Czechoslovakia posing as a State Department third secretary in the US embassy. Eight weeks after his arrival in Prague, Tyler was standing at the cramped and decaying bar cafe he visited for an hour or so after work most days where he could practice a little Czech.
1988 年 10 月，Tyler Vanalden 收到了他的第二个中情局派遣任务，这是他第一次被派往共产主义集团。他被派往捷克斯洛伐克布拉格，冒充美国大使馆的一名国务院三等秘书。抵达布拉格八周后，Tyler 站在一家局促且破败的酒吧咖啡馆里，他每天下班后通常会去那里待一小时左右，在那里他可以练习一点捷克语。
It was a Friday. The room was filling up and growing noisy with talk and music. Tyler looked up. Across the room, a beautiful young woman with short, blond hair was staring at him. She held his eye for a moment, then turned away, bit her lip, lit a cigarette with a shaking hand.
那是周五。房间里挤满了人，谈话声和音乐声喧闹起来。Tyler 抬起头。房间对面，一位美丽的年轻女子，短金发，正盯着他看。她和他对视了片刻，然后移开目光，咬着嘴唇，用颤抖的手点燃了一支香烟。
"What made you suspicious?" his CIA supervisor Ed Marshall asked Tyler nine hours later in a dawn meeting back at the embassy. "You're a good looking guy. It could have been real." "No," said Tyler, "she looked a lot like a girl I went out with in college. When I first saw her I really thought it was her for a second. There's a picture of us in the yearbook kissing at a hockey game. And the little tattoo on her neck. You could see it in the picture."
“什么让你产生怀疑？”他的中情局主管 Ed Marshall 九小时后在使馆的晨会上问 Tyler。“你是个帅小伙子。那可能是真的。”“不，”Tyler 说，“她看起来很像我在大学时交往的一个女孩。当我第一次见到她时，有那么一瞬间我真的以为是她。毕业纪念册里有我们在一场曲棍球比赛中接吻的照片。还有她脖子上的小纹身。你在照片里能看到。”
"And your new friend, this--" Ed examined his notes. "This Jarmila has a tattoo on her neck?" "And the same haircut," Tyler said. "You look as sad as I feel," said the girl in not bad English, 20 uncertain minutes after he first saw her. "Will you join me for a drink?"
“而你的新朋友，这位——”Ed 检查了他的笔记。“这位 Jarmila 脖子上有纹身？”“发型也一样，”Tyler 说。“你看上去和我一样悲伤，”那个女孩用还不错的英语说，在他第一次见到她 20 分钟后，那是一段不确定的时间。“你能陪我喝一杯吗？”
Closer, she didn't really look much like Kim Wilsey , Tyler's happy, wholesome psych-major girlfriend for a few months of his senior year at Colby until she dumped him for being, quote, "emotionally unavailable, artificial, perfect, untouchable, impenetrable, affectless." But the Czech girl looked similar enough to attract him. She ran the tips of her fingers over her tattoo and said she was embarrassed by her poor English.
凑近看，她其实不太像 Kim Wilsey，Tyler 在 Colby 大学的最后一年曾与之交往几个月的那个快乐、健康、心理学专业的女朋友，直到她甩了他，称他“情感疏离、虚假、完美、不可触碰、难以捉摸、无动于衷”。但这个捷克女孩看起来很像，足以吸引他。她用指尖划过纹身，说她因为英语不好而感到尴尬。
"You are from USA. What is it like there? We are told some very strange things about USA," she said with a sad, ironic smile. She would like to visit the USA someday but this is surely not possible because-- she trails off. She's sad. Does the handsome diplomat Tyler know what it is like to be sad? To feel hopeless?
“你来自美国。那里是什么样子？有人告诉我们关于美国的一些非常奇怪的事情，”她带着一种悲伤、讽刺的微笑说。她希望有一天能去美国看看，但这肯定是不可能的，因为——她没说下去。她很难过。这位英俊的外交官 Tyler 知道难过是什么感觉吗？知道绝望是什么感觉吗？
"Yes, I have known this," he says in slightly poorer Czech than he can actually speak. "I would like to help you if I can."
“是的，我经历过，”他用比他实际能说的更差一点的捷克语说。“如果可以的话，我想帮你。”
Her boyfriend has beaten her, she whispers. Tyler looks duly horrified, though he nearly laughs at this excessive, almost baroque ornamentation. "I would like," she whispers so low that Tyler has to lean close and place his ear next to her lips, "to escape from Czechoslovakia somehow and from Igor."
她的男朋友打过她，她低语道。Tyler 看起来适时地感到恐惧，尽管他差点因为这种夸张、近乎巴洛克式的装饰而笑出来。“我想要，”她低声说道，声音低到 Tyler 不得不凑近并将耳朵贴在她的嘴唇旁，“以某种方式逃离捷克斯洛伐克，逃离 Igor。”
She pours wine for them both. "You are most beautiful girl I think to seeing in my whole life," Tyler muttered in clumsy Czech. "Nice," said Ed Marshall, not looking up from his note taking. "Was that true, by the way?" "No. She's cute, nothing special," Tyler lied unnecessarily even as he wondered why.
她为他们俩倒了酒。“你是我这辈子见过的最美的女孩，”Tyler 用笨拙的捷克语嘟囔道。“不错，”Ed Marshall 说，没从记录笔记中抬头。“顺便问一下，那是真的吗？”“不是。她很可爱，没什么特别的，”Tyler 不必要地撒了谎，尽管他想知道为什么。
After almost two hours, a significant silence sat between them until she said, "Do you want to kiss me?" "More than anything I've ever wanted ever." She placed her soft lips on his just long enough for him to taste a drop of her wine. She pulled back hastily.
在大约两小时后，一种显著的沉默存在于他们之间，直到她说，“你想吻我吗？”“比我这一辈子想要任何东西都更想。”她把柔软的嘴唇贴在他嘴唇上，时间刚好够他尝到一滴她的酒。她匆忙地退开了。
"Oh dear God what time it is." She wrenched her head to look at the clock behind her on the stained, brown and white wall and executed a flawless Cinderella. "I am so late. He will know. He will ask me. Oh Tyler, don't forget me. Please, you are so good and I so much need something good." A flustered gathering of her things, a momentary hand on his cheek, and out the door she ran in tearful panic.
“哦，天哪，现在几点了。”她猛地转过头看向身后的棕白相间的脏墙上的时钟，像灰姑娘一样执行了一个完美的动作。“我迟到了。他会知道的。他会问我的。哦 Tyler，别忘了我。求你了，你人真好，我太需要一点美好的东西了。”她慌乱地收拾东西，一只手瞬间划过他的脸颊，然后泪流满面地惊慌跑出了门。
"And you boiled with desire," said Ed Marshall. "Yep," said Tyler. "And felt conspicuous. And got stuck with the tab."
“而你内心欲望沸腾，”Ed Marshall 说。“是的，”Tyler 说。“而且感到引人注目。还得付账单。”
That afternoon, a second meeting with a larger team was held in a secure room at the embassy. They worked up a plan. She would surface again, no question. And when she did, Tyler would churn with contradictions. Relieved she's OK, but his pride injured that she ran off. Infatuated, but cautious. When alcohol entered the scene, he would slowly repeat that he hated his job. The US was a mess, politics a joke, blah blah blah.
那天下午，与一个更大的团队在使馆的一个安全房间召开了第二次会议。他们制定了一个计划。她肯定会再次出现，毫无疑问。而当她出现时，Tyler 会在矛盾中挣扎。庆幸她没事，但又为她跑掉而自尊受损。迷恋，但又谨慎。当酒精介入时，他会慢慢重复他讨厌他的工作。美国一团糟，政治是个笑话，巴拉巴拉。
Every night for a week, Tyler returned to drink at The Wounded Bear. Seven nights, giving up later each night, dribbling smaller and smaller tips behind him. Night eight, December 14, 1988. She appears, very late, after Tyler has apparently drunk quite a bit alone in the noisy crowd.
连续一周的每个晚上，Tyler 都回到“受伤的熊”酒吧喝酒。七个晚上，每天都走得越来越晚，留下的消费也越来越少。第八晚，1988 年 12 月 14 日。她出现了，很晚，在 Tyler 明显在嘈杂的人群中独自喝了不少酒之后。
"Oh thank God," she murmurs as she slides next to him. "I hoped, Tyler, but I did not dare to dream." He pulls away from her. She apologizes. He pouts. "Do not be like that please." "Then how should I be?" "If only you knew what Igor was like you would not be cruel to me. I thought you were different. So this is how you are."
“哦，谢天谢地，”她溜到他身边时低声说。“我曾希望，Tyler，但我不敢梦想。”他推开了她。她道歉。他生气。“别那样，求你了。”“那我该怎样？”“如果你知道 Igor 是什么样的人，你就不会对我这么残忍了。我以为你是不同的。原来你是这样。”
She stands and leaves again. This time though, he swears aloud, drops money on the table, runs after her. He reaches her outside on the cobbled street, the snow just starting to turn heavy. He grabs her arm, turns her towards him. He tries to kiss her.
她站起来又要走。但这次，他大声咒骂，扔下钱在桌上，追了出去。他在鹅卵石街道上追上了她，雪刚开始下得大起来。他抓住她的手臂，把她转向自己。他试图吻她。
"Have you gone mad?" she hisses in terror, pulls away. "We must not be seen together." And she glides over the snow into an alley. He has her tightly now. "My God you are such a handsome," she whispers. "But Igor--"
“你疯了吗？”她在恐惧中嘶嘶地说，退开了。“我们不能被看见在一起。”她滑进雪地里的一条小巷。他紧紧抓住她。“天哪，你真帅，”她低语道。“但是 Igor——”
Igor is cruel, a weasel, a wolf of a man. He terrifies her. She thinks he's having her watched, perhaps even right now. If only she could think of how to be free of him. "I'll kill him," boasted engorged Tyler Vanalden. "I have diplomatic immunity." "Oh dear heaven, God no. He's powerful. He works for--"
Igor 是残忍的，一个黄鼠狼，一个像狼一样的男人。他让她恐惧。她认为他在监视她，甚至可能就是现在。如果她能想到如何摆脱他就好了。“我会杀了他，”热血沸腾的 Tyler Vanalden 吹嘘道。“我有外交豁免权。”“哦，亲爱的上帝，不。他很强大。他为——工作。”
"Of course he does," said Marshall the next morning. "Bless his heart."
“当然他是，”Marshall 第二天早上说。“祝福他的心。”
Weasel Igor worked for some vague division of the secret police. Jarmila certainly didn't know its name or where it was, only that Igor's job was to find out secrets about foreigners working in Czechoslovakia. And she simply could not think of how to escape his violent and lustful embrace described in increasing moist detail. She would go anywhere with Tyler if only she knew she was free and safe.
黄鼠狼 Igor 为秘密警察的一个模糊部门工作。Jarmila 当然不知道它的名字或地址，只知道 Igor 的工作是找出在捷克斯洛伐克工作的外国人的秘密。而她根本无法想到如何逃离他那被描述得越来越潮湿的暴力和淫荡的拥抱。如果她知道自己是自由且安全的，她会跟 Tyler 去任何地方。
His kiss makes her bold. She will meet him. Enough of fear. She whispers an address and a time next Monday night, her friend's apartment. "For God's sake, be discreet going there. I have an idea," she says, "but I am afraid to ask you." "Ask me anything. Anything at all," he says. If you could bring me something to show Igor. Nothing really of value. I don't care what it is, a box of paper clips with your ambassador's name on them, then maybe I'm thinking, I can make Igor think I'm useful. I will not tell him about you of course. I am so frightened of him." She trembled. She kissed him. "Until Monday," she sobbed. And off she ran looking all around in fear.
他的吻使她变得大胆。她会见他。不再恐惧。她低声说出了下周一晚上的地址和时间，她朋友的公寓。“看在上帝的份上，去那儿要谨慎。我有个主意，”她说，“但我不敢问你。”“问我任何事。任何事都可以，”他说。“如果你能带给我一些东西给 Igor 看。没什么真正的价值。我不在乎是什么，一盒写着你们大使名字的曲别针，那么也许我在想，我可以让 Igor 认为我有用。我当然不会告诉他关于你的事。我太怕他了。”她颤抖着。她吻了他。“周一见，”她抽泣着。然后她带着惊恐跑开了，四处张望。
"So who is this traitor, Tyler Vanalden?" Ed Marshall asks Tyler and the team. Tyler, they decided, is eager to please her but still wary of doing any real harm, more out of habit than principle. And so he has photocopied the personal information page from his nominal state department boss's file. Nothing much more than you could find in Washington, DC phone book, but plainly stamped confidential.
“那么这个叛徒 Tyler Vanalden 是谁？”Ed Marshall 问 Tyler 和团队。他们认为 Tyler 急于取悦她，但仍对造成任何真正的伤害保持警惕，这更多是出于习惯而非原则。于是他复印了他名义上的国务院老板文件中的个人信息页。没什么比你在华盛顿特区电话簿里能找到的更多的了，但清晰地盖上了“机密”字样。
This first stolen document was prepared. How Vanalden had procured it was determined. His attitude to his lover for Monday was debated and decided. Bits of pivotal dialogue were drafted and rehearsed.
第一份被盗文件准备好了。Vanalden 如何弄到它的过程已经确定。他周一对情人的态度已经辩论并决定。关键对话的片段已经起草并排练。
"This is for you," said Tyler, panting, nervous, pushing the Syrian envelope into her hands when she opened the door of her friend's apartment. "No," she cried, letting the poisonous thing fall. "I do not care. I do not want to see it. It does not matter. Only you matter." And she pulled Tyler Vanalden onto an old mattress on the floor of the bear, unnecessarily under-heated room where, to the audible accompaniment of a cassette of Beatles songs in Czech, and the inaudible accompaniment of hidden video cameras, Tyler displayed a wide range of emotional turmoil, having passable sex with Jarmila Herbeck of the Czech intelligence service.
“这是给你的，”Tyler 喘着气，紧张地说，在打开朋友公寓门时把那个叙利亚信封塞进她手里。“不，”她哭着说，让那致命的东西掉落。“我不在乎。我不想看。那不重要。只有你重要。”她把 Tyler Vanalden 拉到地板上那张旧床垫上，在那个供暖不足的房间里，伴随着磁带机里捷克语甲壳虫乐队歌曲的清晰伴奏，以及隐藏摄像机的无声伴奏，Tyler 展示了广泛的情绪波动，与捷克情报局的 Jarmila Herbeck 进行了合格的性生活。
"O my brave boy," she exalted an hour later over the document that she saw at once was perfectly worthless, but which was her novice traitor's tentative first step. While she did feel a thrill that she could actually do this, inspire men to treachery, she was also slightly insulted that he didn't price her affections any higher. A form 12C Department of State personnel file cover page? It was like bringing a few wilted daisies.
“哦，我勇敢的男孩，”一小时后她赞叹道，看着那份她一眼就看出完美无用的文件，但这却是她新手叛徒的试探性第一步。虽然她确实感到一种能真正做到这一点的快感，鼓动男人走向背叛，但她也稍微被侮辱了，因为他没给她的爱更高的价格。一份 12C 表格国务院人事文件封面？这就像带了几朵枯萎的雏菊。
She clapped her hands and stared at him in wonder and love. And then her face suddenly wrinkled with worry. "How do I use this now with Igor?" she asked, not having thought through her scheme at all, just a simple girl in way over her head. Tyler took manly control of her fears, rehearsed her. His sister was an actress, he said.
她拍手惊叹，充满爱意地看着他。然后她的脸突然皱成一团，充满忧虑。“我现在怎么用这个对付 Igor？”她问，根本没想过她的计划，只是个脑子进水的单纯女孩。Tyler 在她恐惧中展现了男人的控制力，排练了她。他姐姐是个演员，他说。
Tyler was very happy. The candle did gutter in the cold apartment. The mattress did smell of her perfume. The old town square did glow gold outside the window. That there were other realities shrouding this one did not mean this one wasn't there. "You really are so very beautiful," he said. "Like nothing I've ever seen."
Tyler 非常快乐。蜡烛在寒冷的公寓里摇曳。床垫闻起来有她的香水味。老城广场在窗外闪烁着金光。有其他现实笼罩着这一现实并不意味着这个现实不存在。“你真的非常美丽，”他说。“像我见过的一切都比不上。”
"And now we are up and running," said Marshall. "She'll ask. You'll provide. You'll get better at it. Produce more impressive results. They have to get addicted to you, Tyler. Just like they're trying to get you addicted to her. Now, how are you feeling about all this?" "I'm watching from six miles up," responded Tyler, believing it himself.
“现在我们开始行动了，”Marshall 说。“她会问。你会提供。你会越来越擅长。产生更令人印象深刻的结果。他们必须对你上瘾，Tyler。就像他们正试图让你对她上瘾一样。现在，你对此感觉如何？”“我在六英里高空观看，”Tyler 回应道，连他自己都信了。
Marshall's ad hoc team in the embassy kept control of Operation Brief Encounter for a few more weeks. And into the middle of January, the new lovers met. Late at night, lying in her arms, shaking with cold and fear and shame, he would whisper, "What am I doing? This is all wrong." And Jarmila would have to steady him.
使馆内 Marshall 的临时团队又控制了“短暂相遇行动”几周。进入 1 月中旬，新情侣们见了面。深夜，躺在她的怀里，因寒冷、恐惧和羞耻而颤抖，他会低声说，“我在做什么？这全错了。”而 Jarmila 不得不稳住他。
All of this Tyler understood and duly filed in his well-written reports. But once, she was waiting for him at the apartment sobbing and drinking, and she had a black eye. The sight of it so enraged Tyler that he punched a wall, breaking his wrist. As he's having it bandaged later that night by an embassy nurse, he replays the moments leading up to impact over and over again in his mind's eye trying to understand them. He recalls gently touching Jarmila's eye, showing the appropriate horrified concern tinged with anger, though in fact he was invisibly amused and just curious to see how the Czechs had achieve the effect. Makeup was too risky, so subcutaneous dye? A temporary tattoo? Henna?
所有这些 Tyler 都理解并如实写进他写得很好的报告中。但有一次，她在公寓里等着他，哭泣且喝酒，她有一个黑眼圈。看到那个黑眼圈让 Tyler 暴怒，他打向墙壁，弄断了手腕。那天晚上晚些时候由使馆护士为他包扎时，他一遍又一遍地在脑海中重演导致碰撞的瞬间，试图理解它们。他回想起轻轻触摸 Jarmila 的眼睛，表现出适当的、带着愤怒的惊恐关切，尽管事实上他内心隐隐感到好笑，只是好奇捷克人是怎么实现这种效果的。化妆太冒险，那么皮下染料？临时纹身？指甲花（Henna）？
When he saw and felt that the bruise was real, saw her flinch from his touch, he turned away to gather his thoughts. And as he was deciding how he was supposed to react, he was also trying to understand why he was so upset, though he realized it a split second later. They had really punched her.
当他看到并感觉到淤青是真的，看到她因他的触摸而退缩时，他转过身去收集思路。当他决定他应该如何反应时，他也试图理解为什么他会如此不安，尽管他一秒钟后就意识到原因。他们真的打了她。
He knew that a display of ostensible rage was needed even as he was in fact enraged. He remembers that he thought to myself, I suppose I would punch the wall in frustration, even as he remembers seeing, with some surprise, his fist already approaching the wall. And he remembers thinking, I should pull this punch so I don't hurt myself. But by then, his fist had been seized by the fist it was portraying. And they had punched the wall together.
他知道，尽管他实际上很愤怒，但他需要表现出表面上的愤怒。他记得他想，我想我会因沮丧而打墙，即使他记得他有些惊讶地看到，他的拳头已经在接近墙壁。他记得他想，我应该收力，免得伤害自己。但那时，他的拳头已经被它所描绘的那个拳头占据了。他们一起打了墙。
Jarmila rewinds the video, recalls his face as he approached her, touched her injury. An unforgettable look in his eye, sadness and anger and disappointed plans for the night ahead. He's like a child, lusts and rages and muddled loyalties. And she's helping him grow into a man, a man who will do anything she asks. She knows she, they, will have to be more careful with him now as she watches the green infrared fist hit the black void again and again.
Jarmila 回放录像，回想起他走近她、触摸她伤口时的脸。他眼里有一种难忘的表情，悲伤、愤怒和对夜晚后续计划的失望。他像个孩子，充满欲望、愤怒和混乱的忠诚。而她正在帮助他成长为一个男人，一个会做她要求的一切的男人。当她看着那个绿色红外拳头一次又一次打向黑色虚空时，她知道她——他们——必须更加小心他了。
And there's something more she sees now, replaying his entrance into the apartment, recalling his heart-broken twisted face. He's more than what management and the steering committee have seen in him. He's not just a lustful fool, a boy of the fraternity. And he wouldn't have responded this way, with this devotion and extraordinary intelligence payoff, to just some semi-trained prostitute coughed up by the intelligence service.
还有更多她现在看到的，重放他进入公寓的过程，回想他那心碎且扭曲的脸。他不仅仅是管理层和指导委员会在他身上看到的那些东西。他不仅仅是一个充满欲望的傻瓜，一个兄弟会的男孩。如果只是情报服务吐出来的某个半吊子妓女，他绝不会以这种方式，以这种奉献和非凡的情报回报来回应。
This boy has a unique ability to give himself to something or someone, an ability that would only express itself when he met precisely the right object of devotion, her. She rewinds the tape again.
这个男孩有一种独特的能力可以把自己给予某件事或某个人，这种能力只有在他遇到了恰当的奉献对象——她——时才会表现出来。她再次重放了磁带。
"I really like this one," Johnny 1950 said to Jarmila as he entered one morning, drawing from his briefcase the videocassette of one of her recent evenings with Source Prep School. Someone had labeled the betamax cassette, "February 1, 1989, four and a half stars." "It's excellent work," he continued. "You do excellent work for the Party, comrade."
“我真的很喜欢这个，”Johnny 1950 一天早上走进房间时对 Jarmila 说，从公文包里拿出她最近与“预备学校来源”夜晚相处的录像带。有人给 Betamax 录像带贴上了标签，“1989 年 2 月 1 日，四星半。”“这是极好的工作，”他继续说道。“你为党做了极好的工作，同志。”
He was a creepy little bald man, and she had gagged when he maneuvered to direct the video surveillance of her trysts. He was called Johnny 1950 because in 1950, when he was 11 and a farm boy in Canada, his Canadian, communist parents decided that what was happening in post-war, Eastern Europe was the coming of the world proletarian democratic paradise, the end of history. And they were not going to sit on their six acres in Alberta and let it pass them by. They sold all their belongings and were three of a very, very small number of people who emigrated to Czechoslovakia when most Czechs were pulling their hair out trying to emigrate somewhere like Alberta.
他是个令人毛骨悚然的秃头小个子男人，当他操纵指挥她偷情的视频监控时，她曾感到恶心。他被称为 Johnny 1950，因为在 1950 年，当他是一个加拿大的农场男孩时，他那加拿大共产党的父母认为战后东欧正在发生的事情是世界无产阶级民主天堂的到来，是历史的终结。他们没打算坐在艾伯塔省那六英亩土地上让这一切溜走。他们卖掉了所有家当，是极少数移民到捷克斯洛伐克的人中的三个，而当时大多数捷克人正试图移民到像艾伯塔省那样的地方。
He was ugly and lonely. He repeatedly fell hopelessly in love with unattainably beautiful women. He would have done anything for Jarmila.
他很丑且孤独。他一再无可救药地爱上遥不可及的美女。他会为 Jarmila 做任何事。
[CHANTING DEMONSTRATIONS]
[高喊示威]
Six days of demonstrations against the communist government took everyone by surprise, but the force with which the Czechs dealt with it surprised no one in the US embassy who understood the permanent nature of communism. The arrests of 800, including the dissident playwright Vaclev Havel, proved that this bear was here to stay.
为期六天的反共产主义政府示威让每个人大吃一惊，但捷克人处理它的力度对于美国大使馆里任何理解共产主义永久本质的人来说，一点都不令人惊讶。包括持不同政见的剧作家 Vaclav Havel 在内的 800 人被捕，证明了这只熊将留在这里。
At the same time, Ed Marshall decided that the value of Operation Brief Encounter was proven and should now be managed as a piece of the big picture. So the forged documents, the chronology of hand-offs, the scripts, the course of the love affair and Tyler Vanalden's personality would all be overseen by an operational guidance group back in Langley, Virginia.
与此同时，Ed Marshall 决定“短暂相遇行动”的价值已经得到证实，现在应该作为大局的一部分来管理。因此，伪造的文件、交接的时间顺序、脚本、恋情的过程以及 Tyler Vanalden 的性格都将由弗吉尼亚州兰利的操作指导小组监督。
The operational guidance group set to work, staffed with Czech culture experts, psychologists specializing in the emotional terrain of romance and treachery, an in-house playwright, forgers, counterintelligence strategists, game theorists and two mid-level managers. One, a man named Michael Boortz, who had, for the last three years, been a paid agent of the KGB.
操作指导小组开始工作，配备了捷克文化专家、专门研究浪漫和背叛情感领域的心理学家、内部剧作家、伪造者、反间谍战略家、博弈论专家和两名中层管理人员。其中一位名叫 Michael Boortz，在过去三年里一直是克格勃（KGB）的付费代理人。
It didn't take long for the KGB to identify Operation Brief Encounter and to learn that the false information the Czechs had received from Vanalden had already led to the arrest and near execution of a loyal, Romanian intelligence officer.
克格勃没花多久就识别出了“短暂相遇行动”，并了解到捷克人从 Vanalden 那里收到的虚假信息已经导致一名忠诚的罗马尼亚情报官员被捕并险些被处决。
Clearly, the Czechs should be notified that they were being lied to. But there was a problem. It would be unacceptable to end that operation with any suddenness since the Americans would immediately begin looking for leaks, putting Boortz at unnecessary risk. In the end, they told the head of the Czech service that Source Prep School was contaminated, and any information gained from him was to be considered 100% unreliable. However, under no circumstances was the female agent to be told anything which would cause her to have any, quote, "difficulties playing the role to which she was accustomed."
显然，应该通知捷克人他们被骗了。但有个问题。如此突然地结束那次行动是不可接受的，因为美国人会立即开始寻找泄密者，使 Boortz 置于不必要的风险中。最终，他们告诉捷克情报部门负责人，“预备学校来源”已被污染，从中获得的任何信息都被认为 100% 不可信。然而，在任何情况下，都不得告诉那名女特工任何可能导致她出现——引用——“难以执行她习惯的角色”的困难。
Jarmila sensed that something was wrong. The steering committee for Source Prep School was being reshuffled, and there was a new, second rate team now in charge of her life. The USA attitudes expert, who spoke no English, the playwright who mooned like a little girl over Vaclev Havel stories. And honestly, by now they had more than enough footage to start blackmailing Prep School. Why was she being treated like this? She deserved respect and promotion. She bleached her hair for this. She had gotten a stupid tattoo for this. She had even convinced vile little Johnny 1950 to punch her in the eye twice since he had been so feeble on the first swing. And obviously, she had sacrificed in other ways, even if Prep School was not an ugly man.
Jarmila 感觉到出了问题。“预备学校来源”指导委员会正在改组，现在有一个新的、二流的团队负责她的生活。那个不懂英语的美国态度专家，那个为了 Vaclav Havel 的故事像小女孩一样发呆的剧作家。而且坦白说，到现在为止，他们已经有足够的录像带可以开始勒索“预备学校”了。为什么她会被这样对待？她理应得到尊重和晋升。她为此漂白了头发。她为此弄了个愚蠢的纹身。她甚至说服卑鄙的小 Johnny 1950 两次打了她的眼睛，因为他在第一次挥拳时太软弱了。显然，她在其他方面也做出了牺牲，即使“预备学校”不是个丑男人。
The group in Virginia received a directive in July telling them to slow down a bit. And now Ed had to tell Tyler that weeks were going to pass in which Tyler was simply to quote, "carry on without making any obvious progress, without handing over any tangible lies, just pretending to want her while resisting her efforts to force things."
弗吉尼亚的小组在 7 月收到了一份指令，要求他们慢一点。现在 Ed 不得不告诉 Tyler，未来几周 Tyler 将简单地——引用——“继续进行，不取得任何明显的进展，不提交任何实质性的谎言，只是假装想要她，同时抵制她试图强行推进事情的努力。”
"The director is trying to stoke their hunger, Ty," Ed said. "We want them to focus their desires, really boil for something specific. And then we can pass them a zinger. Look, I'm sorry. I really am. I know this isn't easy. Jesus, Ty, look at your face. Are you still up for this?"
“指挥官正试图煽动他们的饥饿感，Ty，”Ed 说。“我们希望他们专注于自己的欲望，真正为某些具体的事情沸腾。然后我们可以给他们一个猛料。听着，我很抱歉。我真的是。我知道这不容易。上帝，Ty，看看你的脸。你还愿意做吗？”
When he left Ed Marshall's office, Tyler's heart was thumping. He had won himself at least four perfect meetings with her in which there was to be no talk of work. He invited her for a picnic in the countryside.
当他离开 Ed Marshall 的办公室时，Tyler 的心怦怦直跳。他为自己赢得了至少四次与她完美会面的机会，其中不需要谈论工作。他邀请她去乡间野餐。
Her steering committee was divided. No video or audio team could hide near the picnic, argued Yuri from eavesdropping. There was no question of wiring her considering that she and Prep School were likely to become intimate. Johnny 1950 left it up to Jarmila, who couldn't see how she could say no.
她的指导委员会产生了分歧。没有视频或音频团队可以躲在野餐地点附近，负责窃听的 Yuri 反驳道。考虑到她和“预备学校”很可能变得亲密，给她戴窃听器是不可能的。Johnny 1950 把决定权留给了 Jarmila，她看不出她怎么能拒绝。
They ate in a wooded grove, not far from a stream, a lover's scene from the Bohemian countryside under any regime. Tyler fed her grapes. He made her laugh with the story of how he had snuck out of Prague to meet her. She started to say she was nervous about Igor, but he merely put his finger on her lips. "Not now," he said. "No Igor today."
他们在树木繁茂的树林里吃饭，离小溪不远，在任何政权下这都是波希米亚乡村的恋人场景。Tyler 喂她吃葡萄。他讲了他是如何潜出布拉格来见她的故事，让她笑了起来。她开始说她对 Igor 很紧张，但他只是把手指放在她的嘴唇上。“现在不要，”他说。“今天没有 Igor。”
After lunch, he slept soundly with his head on her lap and she stroked his hair. She debated whether to broach work again. When he woke, he described his parents' house on Cape Cod, and Vic, the Labrador he had loved and lost. After a long silence, he said, "You know, I would do anything for you. Just ask. You have more power over me than any blackmailer."
午餐后，他头枕在她腿上睡得很香，她抚摸着他的头发。她犹豫着是否要再次提出工作。当他醒来时，他描述了他父母在科德角的房子，还有他爱过并失去的拉布拉多犬 Vic。沉默良久后，他说，“你知道，我愿意为你做任何事。尽管提。你对我比任何勒索者都有权力。”
"What a strange thing to say," she said quietly. "Just an expression," he said. "But now that I think about it, I don't think I would respond to blackmail. For you though, I'd jump through fire."
“多么奇怪的话，”她安静地说。“只是个表达，”他说。“但现在我想到它，我不认为我会对勒索做出反应。但为你，我会跳进火里。”
He'd been thinking just how to say this for some time now to make it sound like the natural conversation of an unsuspecting, traitorous diplomat. If her service was thinking about making the shift, using the pictures of him they must certainly have had by now, he wanted her to argue against it and for a continuation of the love affair instead.
他已经思考了相当长一段时间该如何说这句话，以使其听起来像一个毫无戒心的叛国外交官的自然对话。如果她的情报部门正在考虑改变策略，利用他们现在肯定拥有的照片，他希望她反对此事，并希望继续这段恋情。
At the steering committee's disorganized meeting on the first of August, Johnny 1950 asked the committee if, considering how little information Source Prep School had provided in the preceding weeks, they thought the time had come to squeeze him, to tell him he'd better start coughing up or the news of his betrayals and some compelling video would be sent to his ambassador. Jarmila argued that this would be a mistake. She just had a feeling. She didn't mention to the committee that she'd rather by a long shot spend evenings with a slavishly devoted lover than have some moron from manipulation pretend to be Igor and run the blackmail while she took a dull holiday on the Black Sea.
在 8 月 1 日指导委员会杂乱无章的会议上，Johnny 1950 问委员会，考虑到“预备学校来源”在过去几周提供的消息很少，他们是否认为现在是时候施压了，告诉他最好开始吐露真相，否则他背叛的消息和一些令人信服的录像带将被送到他大使那里。Jarmila 反驳说那将是一个错误。她只是有种感觉。她没告诉委员会，她宁愿花晚上与一个奴隶般忠诚的情人在一起，也不愿让某个负责操纵的白痴假装是 Igor 来进行勒索，而她却在黑海度过一个沉闷的假期。
"Be patient with him," she told the committee. "Prep School will produce. I know he will."
“对他耐心点，”她告诉委员会。“预备学校会出结果的。我知道他会。”
Meanwhile, Tyler watched as communism crumbled in Hungary and Poland. And he had the strangest sensation as he read each unimaginable dispatch from these other countries. He prayed the democratic virus would be contained, that the Czechs would hold on. But then, the politburo resigned.
与此同时，Tyler 看着共产主义在匈牙利和波兰崩溃。当他读到来自这些国家的每一份不可思议的简报时，他有一种奇怪的感觉。他祈祷民主病毒会被控制住，祈祷捷克人会坚持下去。但随后，政治局辞职了。
[PROTESTING]
[抗议]
December 3. They walked, side by side, as 150,000 protested the communists' last-ditch effort to allow only a minority opposition presence in a new government. They did not hold hands. They pretended to smile at what they saw. Neither of them spoke. Tyler the traitor should have been delighted. It's over. She's free. He did his dirty bit for her without hurting anyone or getting caught. And now it's passed. Jarmila the oppressed should have been delighted. Her country was free. Her future was her own.
12 月 3 日。他们并肩走着，15 万人抗议共产党在选举新政府时只允许少数反对派存在的最后努力。他们没有牵手。他们假装对所看到的一切微笑。他们都没说话。叛徒 Tyler 本应感到高兴。一切都结束了。她自由了。他为她完成了肮脏的工作，没伤害任何人，也没被抓到。现在一切都过去了。受压迫的 Jarmila 本应感到高兴。她的国家自由了。她的未来属于她自己。
If, in character, he told her now she should come with him to the West, escape Igor and their shameful past, but she said no, and she certainly would, then he would be forced to ask her why not. And she would be forced to admit that she'd been lying to him all along and their time together would end.
如果，他现在告诉她应该和他一起去西方，逃离 Igor 和他们可耻的过去，但她说不——她肯定会说不——那么他将被迫问她为什么。而她将被迫承认她一直以来都在骗他，他们在一起的时间也将结束。
Or he could tell her he knew she was a spy for a communist spy service. And now, in the new world unfolding all around them, she would be in danger of arrest and retribution. So she should come to the US, be his pet defector. And they could be together. Of course that would mean admitting that he'd been lying to her since the beginning. That there was no Tyler the traitor. That there was nothing about him that she actually knew. That revelation would also be his first act of actual treachery. It was impossible.
或者他可以告诉她他知道她是共产主义间谍机构的间谍。现在，在他们周围展开的新世界里，她将面临被捕和报复的危险。所以她应该去美国，成为他的宠物叛逃者。他们可以待在一起。当然，那将意味着承认他从一开始就在骗她。不存在什么叛徒 Tyler。关于他的一切她实际上都一无所知。那个揭露也将是他第一次真正的背叛行为。这不可能。
She watched him. Something was not right here. According to all logic, he should have been happy to see the changes underway. He should have been offering her a way out with him. This should mean the end of his spying for her. This should mean the end of Igor's control over her. So why was he silent?
她看着他。这里有些不对劲。按照所有逻辑，看到正在发生的变化他应该感到高兴。他应该给她提供一条和他一起离开的出路。这意味着他为她做间谍活动的结束。这意味着 Igor 对她控制的结束。那么他为什么沉默？
For that matter, why wasn't he telling her to come away with him to Cape Cod? To a wedding on his parents' lawn? Frolicks with some new Labrador? She saw it clearly. He was a liar. That was why. He felt no slavish love for her. He had done what he had done out of lust and weakness, and then lazy momentum, and fear of being blackmailed and nothing else. He was precisely what the playwrights and the planners on the steering committees had always said he was, a depressive, a weakling, lonely and vulnerable, unprincipled and uninterested. In other words, he was an ordinary man.
说到这一点，他为什么不告诉她和他一起去科德角？去他父母草坪上的婚礼？去和一只新的拉布拉多犬嬉戏？她看得很清楚。他是个骗子。就是这样。他一点也不觉得对他奴隶般的爱。他做那些事只是出于欲望和软弱，然后是懒散的惯性，以及对被勒索的恐惧，除此之外别无其他。他正是剧作家和指导委员会策划者们一直所说的那样，一个忧郁的人、懦夫、孤独且脆弱、毫无原则且毫无兴趣。换句话说，他是一个普通人。
She felt foolish. Did this egotist really fear she would want to come away with him? Had she painted herself as needy as all that? How embarrassing now in daylight.
她感到愚蠢。这个利己主义者真的害怕她会想和他一起走吗？她把自己塑造得那么需要人吗？现在在日光下真是太尴尬了。
Tyler looked at her. She had no real feeling for him. That was clear. If any part of her had felt something real in this little farce of theirs, she would say so now. True, she hadn't seen the best of him. She was judging from false evidence. But surely, she'd seen something under that stuff. Surely she'd been having fun too. Surely also he had been the very opposite of emotionally unavailable, artificial, perfect, untouchable, impenetrable, affectless.
Tyler 看着她。她对他没有任何真实的感觉。那是显而易见的。如果她在这场滑稽戏中感受到任何真实的东西，她现在就会说出来。确实，她没见过他最好的一面。她是在根据虚假的证据进行评判。但肯定，她已经看到了那层东西下的一些东西。肯定她也玩得很开心。肯定他也与情感疏离、虚假、完美、不可触碰、难以捉摸、无动于衷完全相反。
Complete silence, except for the throng of cheering, pot-banging Czechs who washed into them. He moved to their left. She moved to their right. The crowd swelled and they both kept walking, not even looking up to be sure they had lost sight of each other.
一片寂静，除了涌向他们的欢呼、敲打锅碗瓢盆的捷克人群。他向左走。她向右走。人群拥挤，他们都继续走着，甚至没抬头确认是否已经失去了对方的踪影。
A month earlier, the IRS had found lumpy, indigestible discrepancies in Michael Boortz's tax returns. An investigation soon revealed that he had 13 separate savings accounts. The subsequent CIA interrogation of a sobbing, farting Boortz revealed much of what Boortz had betrayed over the years, including Operation Brief Encounter.
一个月前，美国国税局在 Michael Boortz 的纳税申报单中发现了笨重、难以消化的差异。一项调查很快揭露他有 13 个独立的储蓄账户。随后中情局对一个抽泣、放屁的 Boortz 的审讯揭露了 Boortz 多年来背叛的大部分内容，包括“短暂相遇行动”。
And so, before his arrest, and in exchange for vague promises of leniency at his trial, Boortz delivered a final flurry of reports to his Soviet handlers, including one put together by the operational guidance group at the request of Ed Marshall.
因此，在他被捕前，作为交换对审判从轻处理的模糊承诺，Boortz 向他的苏联操纵者发送了最后一份报告，包括一份由 Ed Marshall 要求操作指导小组编制的报告。
Jarmila Herbeck, said his report, had been a CIA agent all along. When Vanalden gave her false information, she had knowingly passed it on. And when she was out of her boss's view, she had delivered Czech secrets to Vanalden. This happened in the countryside on picnics.
他的报告称，Jarmila Herbeck 自始至终都是中情局的特工。当 Vanalden 给她虚假信息时，她明知而传了出去。当她不在老板视线范围内时，她向 Vanalden 传递了捷克的秘密。这是在乡间的野餐时发生的。
Well, it was better than nothing, Marshall figured. It would throw the remaining Czechs into chaos. But that was a small comfort when you admitted you had just spent months accomplishing exactly nothing. The poor kid. He called Tyler in, told him he'd been doing a stellar job. Marshall himself was putting Tyler up for an intelligence medal.
好吧，总比什么都没有强，Marshall 想。这会使剩下的捷克人陷入混乱。但当你承认你只是花了几个月时间什么也没做到时，那点安慰微不足道。可怜的孩子。他叫来 Tyler，说他一直做得非常出色。Marshall 自己正在为 Tyler 申请情报奖章。
"The downside though, Ty, is a little more complex. It would appear that possibly they knew about you, about us, from a pretty early time. Actually likely."
“不过缺点是，Ty，有点复杂。看来可能他们很早就知道你了，关于我们。事实上很可能。”
Tyler knew he should be depressed. His life and work for months had been a travesty. He was a videotaped joke. Yet he felt some growing sensation of happiness. Why had the Czechs kept it going if they knew it was garbage? Because she had wanted to. She must have argued for it, for him, propped up the whole shabby structure with justifications just to see him. Every time she met him had been a victory for the two of them, snatched from a dubious Czech service.
Tyler 知道他应该沮丧。他的生活和工作几个月来简直是闹剧。他是一个被录像的笑话。然而，他感到一种增长的幸福感。如果捷克人知道这是垃圾，为什么还要让它继续下去？因为她想要。她肯定为此争论过，为他，支撑起整个破旧的结构，仅仅是为了见他。她每次见到他都是他们两人的胜利，从可疑的捷克情报部门中夺回的胜利。
"Sit down," said Johnny 1950. She had come in to see if there was an office at all today, the day the communist president swore in an opposition government and then resigned. The few people still in the office were visibly worried. Nobody knew if they were going to be the secret service of the new republic or a pile of corpses shot for their work on behalf of the old republic.
“坐下，”Johnny 1950 说。她进来看看今天办公室是否还在，就在共产主义总统宣誓就职反对派政府然后辞职的那天。办公室里仅剩的几个人显得非常担心。没人知道他们将成为新共和国的秘密警察，还是因为替旧共和国工作而被枪杀的一堆尸体。
"There is some news," said Johnny, "I told you to sit down." He was such a turd, this little man, all bossy and official now of all times. "News?" she said, unconcerned. "Yes," he said. "About two weeks ago, Source Prep School was arrested and shipped back to the USA."
“有一些新闻，”Johnny 说，“我叫你坐下。”他真是个废物，这个小个子男人，现在这个时候竟还摆出一副老板和官方的架子。“新闻？”她问道，无动于衷。“是的，”他说。“大约两周前，‘预备学校来源’被捕并被运回了美国。”
She was confused and then realized Tyler was going to jail now. And she wondered if and how she could save him. A sentimental, girlish thought that offended her even as it occurred to her. She nodded, said nothing, turned back to her desk.
她感到困惑，然后意识到 Tyler 现在要坐牢了。她想知道她是否以及如何能救他。一个感伤、幼稚的想法，即使在脑海中闪现时也冒犯了她。她点点头，什么也没说，转回办公桌。
"Wait, don't ask many questions yet," said Johnny. "It gets worse." He examined her beautiful face as he told her that they had been holding a losing hand. Prep School was CIA from the very first pass, not State. And she had never noticed. Her sacrifices had been worthless, Johnny repeated twice more for good measure, trying to soften her up.
“等等，先别问那么多问题，”Johnny 说。“情况变得更糟了。”他打量着她美丽的脸，告诉她他们一直拿着一手烂牌。Tyler 自始至终都是中情局的，而不是国务院的。而她从未察觉。她的牺牲毫无价值，Johnny 又重复了两次以示强调，试图让她软化。
"Wait," he said with a mix of pity and vengeance and pride at knowing more than anyone else. "It gets worse." She laughed out loud. "Yes worse," he said.
“等等，”他说，混合了怜悯、报复和比别人知道得更多的自豪感。“情况变得更糟了。”她大声笑了出来。“是的，更糟，”他说。
"A report has come in from our old friends, perhaps ex-friends, to the East, saying that you have known since day one that Prep School was CIA. Wait, don't talk. It's better if you don't say a word just yet. This report also says you have been sending things the other direction, working for the Americans the whole time. Don't speak. At first, management was going to have you arrested but we actually don't have anyone who does that sort of thing for us right now. We're in a vacuum. Listen and think. If you did this, no one is sure if that's good or bad. If you did this, no one knows what to do about it. Maybe you're a traitor to the Czech people, but maybe you're a hero of the revolution. Don't, don't speak."
“收到了一份来自我们东方的老朋友，也许是前朋友的报告，说你从第一天起就知道‘预备学校’是中情局的。等等，别说话。最好现在别说一个字。这份报告还说你一直在反方向发送东西，一直为美国人工作。别说话。起初，管理层打算逮捕你，但我们现在其实没人做那种事。我们处于真空状态。听着，思考一下。如果你这样做了，没人确定那是好是坏。如果你这样做了，没人知道该怎么办。也许你是捷克人民的叛徒，但也许你是革命的英雄。别，别说话。”
Johnny's tone softened. "Don't worry Jarmila. I can handle this for us. I know how these people think. I grew up among the people you know. You and I, we can help each other."
Johnny 的语气缓和了。“别担心 Jarmila。我可以帮我们处理。我知道这些人是怎么想的。我在你认识的人中间长大。你和我，我们可以互相帮助。”
The department of personnel approved Tyler's quick, unsolicited proposal, agreeing that the venture would place him near potential sources, and that the role fit his real personality and official history excellently. And so in May, 1990, four months after he'd been bundled out of Prague, he returned, a vaguely disgraced but un-indicted ex-diplomat running his own business, hawking to the new democracy an expertise they were sure to need.
人事部门批准了 Tyler 快速、主动提出的建议，同意该项目将使他接近潜在的消息来源，并且该角色非常适合他的真实性格和官方历史。因此，在 1990 年 5 月，也就是他被匆忙赶出布拉格四个月后，他回来了，一个模糊受辱但未被起诉的前外交官，经营着自己的生意，向新的民主政权兜售他们肯定需要的专业知识。
He sat in his hotel room and watched a documentary on Czech TV. It had been made in April by a once banned filmmaker, and was written and produced by a Johnny McDougal. The Revolution's Hidden Heroes it was called. And it profiled those extraordinary souls who had secretly helped the democratic cause from the inside. She looked good on television. Even better as a brunette.
他坐在酒店房间里看捷克电视上的纪录片。那是 4 月由一位曾经被禁的电影制作人制作的，由 Johnny McDougal 编写和制作。“革命的隐形英雄”是它的名字。它描绘了那些从内部秘密帮助民主事业的非凡灵魂。她在电视上看起来不错。作为黑发女郎更好。
The president of Vanalden Communications paid $500 to attend a meet-and-greet in the banquet room of the Palace Hotel. He arrived two hours early, examined the seating arrangement, and discreetly changed it. He returned later to the crowded room alongside representatives of a dozen other political consulting firms. And he drank cocktails and chatted with an assortment of civic forum candidates running in the first free Czech election since 1946.
Vanalden 通讯公司的总裁支付了 500 美元参加皇宫酒店宴会厅的见面会。他提前两个小时到达，检查了座位安排，并谨慎地进行了更改。他后来与十几家其他政治咨询公司的代表一起回到了拥挤的房间。他喝着鸡尾酒，与参加自 1946 年以来第一次自由捷克选举的各种公民论坛候选人聊天。
Dinner was served. He took his time going to the seat he had usurped. "You look like someone I once knew," he said to the parliamentary candidate seated to his left. "I have that kind of face," she said, smiling. "I saw you on television," he said. "You sacrificed terribly for the revolution." She laughed. "You can't begin to imagine."
晚餐开始了。他花时间走到他篡夺的座位上。“你看上去像我曾经认识的某个人，”他对坐在他左边的议会候选人说。“我有那种脸，”她笑着说。“我在电视上见过你，”他说。“你为革命做出了巨大的牺牲。”她笑了。“你无法想象。”
"You know," he said, "I think I could be of great help to you in your campaign." "I'd have to consult with my fiance," she said, gesturing to the suddenly despondent bald man who, far away down the long table, had just recognized Vanalden. "But I doubt he will protest. Tell me about yourself."
“你知道，”他说，“我想我在你的竞选中能帮上大忙。”“我得咨询我的未婚夫，”她说，指着远方长桌旁那位突然感到绝望的秃头男人，他刚刚认出了 Vanalden。“但我怀疑他会抗议。告诉我关于你自己的事。”
Arthur Phillips, reading an abridged version of his story, "Wenceslas Square," which first appeared in a collection of essays and short stories entitled Wild East , Stories From the Last Frontier. Arthur Phillip's most recent novel is Angelica .
Arthur Phillips，朗读他故事“瓦茨拉夫广场”的删节版，该故事首次出现在题为《狂野东部：来自最后前沿的故事》的论文和短篇小说集中。Arthur Phillips 的最新小说是《当归》。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia, who reminds you every pledge drive--
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板 Torey Malatia 负责，他在每次认捐活动时提醒你——
"Don't forget me, please. You are so good. And I so much need something good."
“别忘了我，求你了。你人真好。我太需要一点美好的东西了。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是 Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。